Perfekt. Ja, dann, hallo und herzlich willkommen zum
Beifen Crash Course D. Mit diesem Crash Course, mit diesem letzten Crash Course,
solltet ihr praktisch alle Grundprinzipien von Beifen kennengelernt haben, die ihr dann
für Asylent-1 brauchen wird. Es gibt ja natürlich noch weitere Crash Courses zu
Pandas und Zympai. Ja. Das sollte jetzt gefixt sein.
Passt dann ändere ich das nach der Vorlesung um.
Genau, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, im Kalender ist heute die Vorlesungseinheit ein bisschen länger eingetragen.
Sie sollte aber eigentlich gleich lang bleiben wie alle davor. Wir können es aber bis Sie verlängern,
falls ihr noch kurz Asylent-1 kurz durchgehen wollt. Ich starte sonst gleich mal mit dem Feedbacken.
Schauen wir, können Sie mal...
Und ich schaue mir kurz an.
Stimmt zu Asylent-1 gab es gestern noch technische Schwierigkeiten, deshalb ist es erst ab heute verfügbar.
Aber ja, ich schaue mal...
Ich habe es gestimmt.
Ich habe es gestürzt, ich habe es gestürzt.
Die vorletzte Frage haben wir noch gar nicht durchgemacht.
Ich habe jetzt mal dringelassen, damit ihr mal seht, was wir heute dann durchgehen werden.
Ihr könnt euch mal Gedanken darüber machen und sonst ist es auch egal.
Ich habe es gestürzt, ich habe es gestürzt.
Passt, ich gebe euch noch eine Minute und dann bin ich.
Ich gebe euch noch eine Minute und dann bin ich.
All right.
Passt, also hier haben wir es so, dass wir praktisch ein If-Statement in der Vorschleife haben, die uns ab einer gewissen Zahl die Schleife abricht.
Praktisch die Schleife geht da nicht von 0, 1, 2, 3, 4 durch, sondern bricht da ab, sobald die Summe hier erreicht ist, also sobald die Summe größer als 4 ist.
Das sieht man hier, also range, das liefert uns ja praktisch eine zahlende range ab und wir addieren hier dann immer praktisch diese Laufvariable zu unserer initialen Variable,
dass wir praktisch hier in diesem Fall 0 plus 0, 0 plus 1, 1 plus 2, 3 plus 3 und 3 plus 3 ist 6, 6 ist größer als 4 und da bricht man ab.
Und deshalb kommen wir da auch nie wirklich zur letzten Summe.
Ist das soweit verständlich oder gibt es dazu noch Fragen?
Genau, also wichtig bei unseren verdienten Datentypen von dictionary sets, duples und Listenes, dass praktisch nur Listen und Duple geordnet sind, was heißt geordnet?
Wenn ich das kurz zeige, wenn ich zum Beispiel eine Liste definiere,
und das gleiche mit einem Duple, dann bleiben diese Werte fixiert an dieser Position, das heißt da ist intern dann immer ein Index zugewiesen,
1, 2, 0, 1, 2, 0, 1, 2, hingegen bei einem Set oder bei einem Dictionary, die haben keine Indizierung, also da gibt es das 0, 1, 2 nicht,
also ich kann nicht Set an der Stelle 0 machen, das heißt intern beißen weiß nicht, dass der 3 an Position 1 oder 0 ist, 2 an 1 und 1 an 2,
sondern beißen haut ihr einfach in einen Haufen rein und Geschichte ist erledigt,
hingegen bei der Liste und beim Duple ist das komplett fixiert, das heißt ich kann da wirklich auf jeden diese einzelnen Zahlen zugreifen,
mithilfe des Index und eben genau das gleiche mit Dictionaries ist wie bei Sets, praktisch haben wir ja diese Values, aber intern sind die nicht geordnet,
das heißt da wird jetzt auch nicht, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel ich ein Dictionary definiere und dann füge ich dann noch einen zweiten Key hinzu zum Beispiel Key 0,
dann wird diese 0 hier nicht vor dem 10er eingefügt oder irgendwie, sondern das wäre dann einfach eine ungeordnete,
sprichert das einfach irgendwie ab, sicher werden wie ähnlich zu der Liste oder zum Duple können wir eben auch hier mit diesen eckigen Klammern zugreifen,
aber hier wichtig ist, dass es kein Index, also es ist keine Numerierung, sondern es ist ein Key als ein Schlüssel und der kann irgendwas sein,
also der muss jetzt nicht eine Zahl sein, der kann auch ein String sein oder eben auch ein Boolean oder irgendwas und das ist eben der Riesenunterschied zur Liste und Duple.
Da geht es mir halt nicht richtig, ja das Interessante bei Sets ist, dass es keine Duplikate gibt,
das heißt hier zum Beispiel in diesem Beispiel haben wir hier zweimal A drin stehen, das geht bei Sets natürlich nicht,
Sets löscht einfach die zweite A und auch das zweite C raus, genauso wie hier A, A, C, C und auch ganz wichtig Sets können natürlich sowohl Strings als auch Integer oder Floats enthalten.
Okay, das sind auch mehrheitlich richtig, da ist so, wir definieren initial ein Dictionary, wie ihr es seht, ganz wichtig geschwone Klammern und der Doppelpunkt.
Dann fügen wir einen zweiten Value hinzu mit dem Key 4, 5, 6, das heißt wir haben da jetzt im Dictionary Students nicht nur 1, 2, 3 Max drin,
sondern auch noch 4, 5, 6 Maria und dann im dritten Statement hier überschreiben wir den Value vom Key 1, 2, 3, das heißt praktisch hier haben wir ja 1, 2, 3 Max drin stehen
und dann überschreiben wir das, weil das ist ja schon definiert hier, mit Lukas, das heißt wir kommen hier keinen Sünderkserre
und es steht da praktisch dann auch Lukas drin, also das ist so generell überhaupt falsch, ja.
Ist das mit dem Dictionary so einigermaßen verständlich oder soll ich da nochmal kurz was erklären?
Okay, da gibt es noch ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Verständnis.
Ja, eben das erste Beispiel hier zum Beispiel Vor- und Nachnahme von Studierenden als Key geht natürlich auf jeden Fall,
in der echten Welt macht man das auch normalerweise anders, zum Beispiel wenn wir jetzt in der Uni sind wird normalerweise nicht nach Vor- und Nachnahmen gefragt,
sondern nach der Matrickelnummer, weil die Matrickelnummer einfach ein wirklich einzigartiger Wert ist, den ich euch allen zuweisen kann,
zum Beispiel könnte es sein, dass es 2 Gregor Meier gibt, aber es gibt also die 2 Gregor Meier haben nicht die gleiche Matrickelnummer.
Und das ist das Coole, deshalb ist das ja auch hier bisschen problematisch, zum Beispiel wenn man das jetzt wirklich machen würde,
so in diesem Fall und praktisch Vor- und Nachnahmen als Key abspeichert und die Matrickelnummer als Value,
könnte es sein, dass der Value überschrieben wird, weil wir ja 2 Personen mit gleichen Namen haben könnten.
Hingegen die Matrickelnummer ist einzigartig, da werden wir keine Probleme haben, dass es überschrieben wird.
Das Gleiche auch mit Songname und Band-Erke, das ist generell problematisch, wir können es auch nicht umdrehen.
Das ist eben so ein Fall, wo es gibt nämlich Songs, die haben den gleichen Namen und wir haben auch Bands, die den gleichen Namen haben.
Oder generell, wir haben praktisch eine Band-Kamera Songname haben, also Band-Namen haben wir weniger Problem.
Da muss man sich was anderes einfallen lassen, also entweder wir geben dem Songnamen eine bestimmte Nummer
oder der Band eine bestimmte Nummer, aber ja, umgekehrt geht es glaube ich generell nicht.
Und ihr seht da eigentlich so ein Schema, das sich da ausarbeitet, und zwar haben wir immer eher im Key die Nummer
und dann im Value eigentlich einen Stringwert oder so.
Also es ist meistens der Fall, dass wir eben sagen, okay, die Bustleitzahl machen wir als Key, weil das ist eine einzigartige Nummer.
Ortsnamen können auch wieder doppelt vorkommen, deshalb ist es auch wieder problematisch.
Ja, da mehrheitlich auch schon wieder richtig abgestimmt, also Funktionen, das werden wir heute durchmachen.
Warum gibt es nichts aus?
Weil wenn wir das einfach reinhauen in unserer Kurzheile, dann definieren wir nur diese Funktion,
aber wir rufen die Funktion noch gar als nirgends auf, dazu aber später mehr.
Okay, dann noch zu den offenen Fragen.
Was sind die unterschiedlichen Listen, Doubles, List Z und so weiter mit dem zugehörigen Zeichen?
Also wir haben es sehr kurz durchmacht.
Noch mal Listen sind mit den eckigen Klammern.
Das Wichtige da ist, man kann die Werte da drinnen verändern, das heißt man kann Werte rauslöschen,
man kann Werte hinzufügen, wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert mit Erlöschen zum Beispiel mit dem Delete Keyword
und dann zum Beispiel Liste an der Stelle und hier den Index oder auch zum Beispiel mit Remove
und da einen bestimmten Wert reingeben, hier nicht einen Index, sondern hier den Wert, den ihr löschen wollt
und dann noch hinzufügen, vielleicht wisst ihr es noch, das ist Abend.
Doppel hingegen, das machen wir mit den runden Klammern, da kann man nichts löschen,
da kann man nichts hinzufügen, wenn die mal definiert sind, dann kann man nur auf die einzelnen Werte zugreifen
oder auf das gesamte Doppel, da können wir zum Beispiel eben sagen Doppel an der Stelle 0,
also da wieder den Index und das wäre in diesem Fall 1.
Setz hingegen, da können wir eben nicht mit dem Index zugreifen, die machen wir mit den geschwungenen Klammern
und da wichtig zu wissen ist, dass wir praktisch keine Duplikate drin haben,
also es gibt da nicht so was, also da wird ein Einzel dann rausgelöscht
und wir bekommen eigentlich nur so was dann stehen
und da auch wieder ähnlich zur Liste, können wir aber auch Sachen hinzufügen und wieder rauslöschen
und da gibt es dann eben eigentlich diese mathematischen Operatoren, die wir jetzt kennen gelernt haben,
da haben wir eben zum hinzufügen das Add, dann haben wir noch andere, da haben wir das End und das Oder,
also das wäre auch in diesem Fall Union und das wäre in dem Fall Intersect
und dann gibt es auch noch das Minus und das Minus ist einfach, wenn ich hier Set 1 und hier Set 2 habe,
dann lösche ich praktisch hier in Set 1 alle Elemente raus, die Set 1 und Set 2 gemeinsam haben.
Also S1 ist 1, 2 und S2 ist 2, 3, wenn wir da S1 minus S2 machen, dann bekommen wir 1 raus,
weil 2 in beiden vorkommt und deshalb wird 2 rausgelöscht, 3 kommt nicht vor, deshalb wird es einfach ignoriert.
Wie sieht das Feedback bei vorzeitiger Abgabe des Assignments aus?
Ihr bekommt da wahrscheinlich, also hat der Mail-Seite, wo dann zu den einzelnen Funktionen dazusteht,
ob es die Test-Cases durchlaufen sind oder nicht und ganz unten solltet ihr dann auch noch mögliche Fehler kriegen,
falls ihr den Coding-Standard nicht einhält, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Assignment 1 macht ihr von zu Hause aus, genau, da habt ihr jetzt bis 9. November Zeit, das in aller Ruhe zu machen.
Falls es noch Zeit ist, können wir ganz zum Schlusskurs die Angabe von Assignment 1 durchgehen.
Ich habe jetzt auch in der Zwischenzeit das Abgabetatum geändert, das sollte jetzt passen.
Wenn man bei Assignment 1 ein Code nicht weiß, davon Google zu raten,
sie natürlich könnt ihr Google verwenden, ihr könnt generell alle Ressourcen verwenden, die euch zur Verfügung stehen.
Ihr sollt nur aufpassen, dass, falls ihr jetzt Code von irgendwo her kopiert,
könnte es sein, dass jemand anderes das Gleiche gemacht hat und es dadurch zum Plagiat kommt.
Also wenn man genau, also wenn man das jetzt googelt und man findet genau die Abgabe so im Internet
und kopiert die einfach rein, dann wird das als Plagiat gezählt.
Der Code ist jetzt nicht so lang, also müsste jetzt nicht ultra viel programmieren
und da kann es schon sein, dass es manchmal zur gleichen variablen Namen kommt und so.
Also jetzt müsste jetzt da keine Angst haben, dass jetzt nur weil jetzt zwei Studierende aus Versehen
jetzt den gleichen variablen Namen oder sowas verwenden, dass das jetzt gleich bei uns rot aufleuchtet.
Bei uns ist es wirklich so, dass wenn der Code sehr offensichtlich Plagiat ist,
dann werden wir uns bei euch melden, aber ja, solltet sonst keine Probleme bereiten.
Ja, ihr müsst noch viel lernen, ja.
Ich hoffe, mit diesen vier Einheiten habt ihr dann schon mal die Grundkenntnisse kennengelernt,
damit ihr es einem einst zuerst mal bewältigen könnt.
Generell eigentlich sollten eigentlich eh die meisten Grundkenntnisse sein,
mit denen ihr ziemlich viel programmieren könnt.
So kompliziert ist es dann auch wieder nicht.
Natürlich jetzt die Funktionen, wie wir es sehen, können dann schon sehr kompliziert werden am Anfang,
aber ich hoffe, ihr versteht das dann alle.
Passt, dann werde ich da weitermachen.
Gibt es sonst noch Fragen?
Bevor wir zu den Funktionen kommen, möchte ich davor noch was anderes machen
und das ist das Input unter die While-Schleifen.
Und dann gehen wir zu den Funktionen über.
Zu den Inputs ist so, wir haben bis jetzt kennengelernt, okay, man kann Print schreiben,
man kann addieren, subtrahieren und so weiter und so fort.
Aber was, wenn ich möchte, dass mein Programm den Benutzer fragt, ob er mir einen Input gibt.
Das heißt, da kommt dann so ein tolles Fragefenster auf und sagt, okay, schreibt mir den Wert rein,
damit ich mit dem Wert was anfangen kann.
Und das Ganze können wir eben mit diesem Input machen, das schaut dann so aus mit dem Code.
Das heißt, wir haben hier unsere Variable
und dann haben wir diese Input-Funktion.
Und da können wir dann noch die Frage reinstellen oder einen Text hinzufügen.
Das ist aber optional, also das muss man gar nicht machen.
Und dann sobald der User was reingeschrieben hat und dann Enter drückt,
dann wird das in dieser Variable gespeichert
und dann können wir diese Variable, also diesen Text, den wir da reingeschrieben haben, verwenden.
Ich kann das kurz herzeigen.
Dann noch mal eine Reite oben drauf.
Machen wir hier.
Wenn man das bei ihr erwischt, was du dir Code machst,
sagen wir Name, Input.
Also hier als Beispiel, wenn ich nichts reinschreib.
Dann seht ihr hier ganz oben,
kommt diese Eingabe-Leiste hier
und da könnt ihr jetzt was reinschreiben.
Dann werden wir uns das dann anschauen.
Dann wird dieser Wert hier als String wichtig.
Da kommt immer als Ergebnis ein String raus,
wird dann in diese Variable gespeichert
und dann können wir damit was anfangen.
Wie wichtig, das ist ein String,
weil es kann auch Probleme bereiten.
Stellt euch vor, der User ist ein bisschen unhandlich mit der Zastatur
und schreibt dir zum Beispiel davor noch ein Leerzeichen rein
oder keine Ahnung was.
Oder wie gesagt, das ist ja auch ein String.
Das heißt, wenn der dann eine Zahl reinschreibt,
dann ist das immer noch ein String.
Dann kann man da ein paar Sachen machen.
Also wir haben ja dann diesen Wert hier
in dieser Variable Name gespeichert
und sagen wir, ich fühle das noch mal aus.
Und ich mache da jetzt ein Leerzeichen
oder zwei oder drei.
Da seht ihr, da sind da jetzt auch Leerzeichen drin.
Und wie können wir diese Leerzeichen zum Beispiel weglöschen?
Das kann man mit Strip machen.
Und dann werden euch diese Leerzeichen wieder gelöscht.
Und natürlich kann es sein,
dass eben die großen Kleinschreibungen nicht passen und so.
Und da kann man dann eben auch wieder
diese String-Methoden verwenden.
Die haben wir hier schon ein bisschen kennengelernt,
zum Beispiel Lower, Upper, Title.
Da kann man dann den Text in Kleinbuchstaben verwandeln,
in Großbuchstaben verwandeln
oder schauen, dass immer da erste Buchstabe großgeschrieben wird.
So zum Beispiel.
Zuerst löschen wir praktisch hier.
Die Leerzeichen müssen nicht nur vorne sein,
die können auch hinten sein.
Wenn sie dazwischen sein, werden sie aber nicht draus gelöscht.
Also sie werden nur mit Strip,
werden sie nur vorne und hinten gelöscht.
Da gibt es auch noch R-Strip oder L-Strip,
wo ihr dann an der rechten Stelle nur
oder an der linken Stelle nur weglöschen könnt.
Das könnt ihr dann selber ausprobieren.
Zum Casting.
Also wir haben ja jetzt das Problem,
wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert,
wenn wir hier eine Zahl haben,
also hier ein Integer,
und dann die zweite Zahl ist aber ein String.
Was passiert, wenn wir die zusammen addieren,
kann man einen Fehler.
Und da, falls ihr euch noch erinnern könnt,
eine vorherige Vorlesung,
da haben wir dieses Casting,
mit dem wir praktisch diesen String wieder umwandeln,
in etwas anderes,
zum Beispiel eben in ein Integer,
in ein Float, in ein Boolean,
oder eben auch,
kann man natürlich auch umgekehrt machen,
dass man eine Zahl in ein String umwandelt.
Genau, und da gibt es eben
viele verschiedenen Datentypen.
Das heißt, wir müssen zuerst casten,
bevor wir addieren.
Das können wir auch kurz ausprobieren.
Zum Beispiel, wenn wir jetzt da 12,
plus das hier machen,
was passiert?
Wenn ich da 3 rein schreibe,
mag er nicht.
Da bekommen wir diesen Type-Error raus.
Praktisch die Datentypen
stimmen wir nicht miteinander ein.
Was machen wir?
Wir casten das Ganze einfach zu einem Integer,
und dann haben wir die Daten,
die wir in einem String haben,
und jetzt, wenn wir da 3 reinschreiben,
funktioniert so eine Probleme.
Natürlich,
wie gesagt, da gibt es wieder,
also das ist ja dann wieder Casting.
Das heißt, wenn wir da
4 und noch ein String dazuschreiben,
funktioniert unser Casting nicht mehr.
Was müssen wir da machen?
Da müssen wir zuerst
alles rauslöschen, was keine Zahl ist,
damit das funktioniert.
Und da gibt es natürlich auch wieder
Möglichkeiten, wie man das macht.
Ich bin uns nicht ganz sicher, ob das eine Aufgabe ist,
deshalb werde ich das jetzt nicht erwähnen,
falls ihr
da Probleme habt,
dann könnt ihr da immer noch
im Titel eine Frage stellen,
und ich werde euch das beantworten.
Genau, dann gehen wir noch zu den Wailoops weiter.
Und die Wailoops,
das ist auch eine Art von Schleife,
also wir kennen ja die einere Schleife,
das war die Vorloop,
und jetzt haben wir auch noch diese Wailoop,
und die Wailoop ist ein bisschen speziell.
Wie ihr seht,
übersetzt ist das so, was wie so lange
diese Bedingung erfüllt ist,
und wird das Ganze
in einer Endloschleife,
oder wird das praktisch diese Ausweisung ausführen.
Das heißt,
hier haben wir eine Kondition,
wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert,
das haben wir es auch beim IF,
das heißt praktisch, es ist sehr ähnlich zum IF,
nur wird das Ganze
einfach wiederholt,
solange diese Kondition TRUE ist.
Also das ist wieder ein Bolian hier,
das schaut dann ungefähr so aus.
Zum Beispiel haben wir hier eine Variable X,
die wir mit 0 definieren,
und solange X
als 3 wiederholt sich das Ganze,
und wie ihr es schon seht,
können das auch zu Problemen führen,
weil sagen wir zum Beispiel,
wir vergessen das hier,
was glaubt ihr, was passiert?
Also, wir vergessen hier
X zu inkrementieren mit 1.
Genau, da haben wir eine Endloschleife,
weil praktisch hier
X nie verändert wird,
das heißt X bleibt immer 0,
das heißt,
das hier ist praktisch immer wahr,
und wir kommen da nicht mehr raus.
Und das kann euch vielleicht auch
beim Live-Programmen passieren,
also da hatten wir über die Jahre
schon öfters Problemen,
dass jemand eine Weilschleife definiert
und vergisst das hier zu machen,
dass praktisch diese Variable,
die wir hier in der Bedingung haben,
nicht verändert
und dann plötzlich reagiert
mein JupyterLab nicht mehr
in Wirklichkeit schon,
es ist nur eine Endloschleife,
die praktisch ewig durchläuft.
Da kann man natürlich auch wieder,
also wir können das mal ausprobieren,
was passiert, wenn man so eine Endloschleife gerät,
die einfachste wäre,
zum Beispiel,
while true,
also,
so lange war,
machen wir irgendwas,
so,
jetzt läuft das hier,
läuft, läuft, läuft, läuft,
und das hört nicht mehr auf,
und da können wir dann einfach hier,
das hier,
manuell sagen,
okay, wir stoppen hier,
und kommt dieses Keyboard interrupt,
ganz interessant bei Jupyter
ist so, also wenn ihr das in Notebook macht,
dann speichert er trotzdem
noch diesen Wert, das heißt,
wir können den auch mal auslesen,
und jetzt wissen wir,
wie oft diese Weisschleife
während diesen fast 14 Sekunden
hier durchlaufen ist,
das heißt, wir haben hier
eine Million
33 Millionen
Nein, 336 Millionen mal ist
diese Weisschleife in der Zwischenzeit durchlaufen.
Genau,
aber für was
verwendet man so eine Weisschleife eigentlich?
Für was ist das notwendig?
Also,
sagen wir zum Beispiel,
ihr wollt ein Programm machen,
das zum Beispiel
so eine Attaschenrechner,
dann könnt ihr eben
hier schauen,
okay, ich will so lange
Sachen addieren,
oder eben hier zum Beispiel
machen wir einfach so eine Art
Papageide und sind immer wieder das,
das rausschreibt,
was wir reingeschrieben haben.
Und wir schauen einfach, bis dieser Input
quitt ist, das heißt praktisch,
wenn ich dann immer ein Input quitt reinschreib,
dann ist
diese
diese Condition
nicht mehr erfüllt, weil, wie ihr hier seht,
haben wir hier einen Ungleich,
also dieses Rufenzeichen macht
das Ganze nicht gleich,
und sobald das nicht mehr erfüllt ist,
bricht die Schleife ab
und dann bändet unser Programm.
Genau,
nochmal zu Endloschleifen, also da gibt es eben
wie gesagt, die einfachste ist diese
Wild True Schleife,
Wild True ist immer wahr,
und die bricht praktisch nie mehr ab.
Und was kann man da
sonst noch so machen,
wenn wir euch zurückerinnern,
wir können hier entweder so
das machen, aber wir können das Ganze
auch so machen, dass wir einfach sagen,
wir haben eine Endloschleife,
und dann, wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert,
gibt es hier dieses Break Statement,
mit der wir praktisch die Schleife
abbrechen können.
Da können wir einfach so ein tolles If
reinhauen, und das macht eigentlich
nichts anderes, wie das, was da vorgemacht
wurde.
Hier im Gegensatz schauen wir aber,
wirklich, der Usain would quit
es, also nicht, nicht gleich,
sondern ist gleich quit.
Genau.
Ist das soweit klar, oder
soll ich da nochmal kurz was wiederholen?
Okay.
Was dann geht, da eigentlich
ist schon zu den eigentlich
wichtigsten Themen von heute,
zu den Funktionen über.
Und wenn ihr euch jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen nachdenkt,
wir haben hier schon ein paar Funktionen
durchgemacht, zum Beispiel
das LEN, wenn ihr euch
daran erinnert.
Was macht das LEN?
Also da haben wir eine Liste
rein zum Beispiel.
Das LEN,
wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert,
das ist,
das kommt
vom englischen Wort
LENGF.
Das ist da,
das ist praktisch Länge
bedeutet.
Wir wollen praktisch die Länge
von unserer Liste haben,
und die ist da 1, 2, 3.
Das heißt, wir bekommen hier eine 3 raus.
Und das hier
ist so eine Funktion.
Das heißt, wir bekommen hier
diese Liste als Input
und dann bekommen
ein Output, das wäre dann unser 3.
Praktisch.
Schaut dann so aus.
Wir haben dann praktisch dieses LEN Keyword,
macht dann im Hintergrund
irgendwas.
Was praktisch
dann zu diesem 3
führt.
Genau,
und da haben wir dann diesen Output.
Normalerweise, dieser Output wird mit diesem
Return Keyword zurückgegeben.
Nicht jede Funktion
muss dieses Return haben.
Dann haben wir eine Funktion
ohne Rückgabewert.
Kann zum Beispiel auch einfach nur
einen Konsolen-Output machen, also mit
Print.
Das heißt, wir bekommen hier die
Parameter in ein
Pfeilspeichern
oder in andere
Variablespeichern.
Zum Beispiel
Print ist ja auch so ein Statement,
als eine Funktion.
Gehen wir das mal anhand von diesem
Beispiel hier durch.
Das heißt, wir haben hier Print,
dieses Attest.
Das heißt, wir haben hier 4 Parameter.
Die Funktion ist Print.
Das hier.
Und ausgegeben
wird praktisch dann in der Konsole
dieses Attest.
Ebenes gleich mit LEN zum Beispiel.
Da haben wir auch hier in diesem Fall
unser Argument,
was in diesem Fall praktisch diese Liste ist.
Und dann bekommen wir diesen Rückgabewert.
Das ist ein bisschen return
Value.
In diesem Fall.
Und wenn wir so eine Funktion selber definieren,
dann schaut das ungefähr so aus.
Also, was fällt
da auf? Einerseits dieses Def.
Das Def
kommt von Define.
Define Funktion.
Also, das solltet ihr auf jeden Fall merken.
Dann unseren Funktionsnamen.
Wie ihr seht, haben wir da
alles kleinpustamen.
Und
wenn es ein längerer Funktionsnamen
ist und mehrere Wörter beinhaltet,
dann könnt ihr das mit diesem
Anderscore hier trennen.
Das kann natürlich auch einfach Def Test heißen.
Also, wie ihr wollt.
Und dann haben wir diese,
hier haben wir einen Parameter.
Also, es ist eine Variable, die wir dann
hier definieren.
Und die können wir dann hier verwenden.
Aber nur in
praktisch in diesem Funktionsblock.
Wie ihr seht, haben wir hier wieder eine Einrückung.
Und dann können wir da mit
unserem Format String
diesen Parameter ausgeben.
In diesem Fall würde
das einfach
U-Past 13 to this Funktion.
Und wie ihr hier seht,
wenn ihr euch zurückerinnert
an die Feedbackerfrage,
da haben wir gehabt, dass praktisch
nichts ausgegeben wird.
Und das liegt daran, dass wir das nicht gemacht haben.
Wir haben praktisch diese Funktion aufgerufen
in unserem Code.
Wichtig, das ist dann nicht
im Funktionsblock, sondern
irgendwo anders.
Also, das muss dann mindestens auf derselben
Ebene sein, wie die Definition
der Funktion.
Kann aber auch dann
trotzdem noch weiter drin sein.
Wenn die jetzt zum Beispiel
im Funktionsblock drin ist,
dann nennt man das eine rekursive Funktion.
Das heißt, die ruft sich immer selber auf.
Das ist auch so eine Art Endloschleife.
Genau.
So eine Funktion ist praktisch
einfach so eine Art benannter Codeblock.
Also, sagen wir mal, ich hab 100 Zeigen Code.
Und möchte den
wiederverwenden können,
wenn ich diesen Codeblock mit dieser Define
Function
und dann kann ich eben diese Function
einfach immer wieder aufrufen
und das wird mir in dieser 100 Zeigen
Code einfach wieder aufrufen.
Wichtige Funktionen,
die wir ja schon kennengelernt haben,
ist dieses LAN, das Print und das Input
und definiert es eben mit diesem
Def, Name der Funktion
und dann eine Parameterliste.
Das werden wir dann genau
jetzt dann gleich genau durchmachen
und wichtig ist eben, der Codeblock
ist wie beim IF oder bei einer Vorschleife
oder einer Weisschleife
eingerückt, also wieder unsere vier Leerzeigen.
Und dann ganz zum Schluss,
falls wir jetzt
in diesem Codeblock was generieren,
dann können wir diesen Wert
natürlich dann auch wieder
an unseren äußeren Codeblock zurückgeben
und das machen wir mit Return.
Dazu aber auch gleich mehr.
Also so einfache Funktionen,
also Beispiele sind
zum Beispiel hier,
hier haben wir
die erste Funktion, die ist die
TestSimple,
wie ihr seht, hat die kein Parameter definiert,
das geht natürlich auch,
also die muss kein Parameter haben
und dann rufen wir die auf
und das heißt,
hier passiert ja nichts,
hier passiert ja auch nichts,
dann wird hier
diese Funktion aufgerufen,
das heißt, ihr bekommt hier dann
dieses Print Statement
mit High Everyone,
das wird dann in die Konsole ausgegeben
und dann kommt hier zum nächsten
Funktionsaufruf,
da springt dann hier wieder rein,
hier übergeben wir einen Parameter,
String Hello,
da wird dann hier mit dieser Print Funktion
in die Konsole aufgerufen
und dann springen wir wieder zurück
und gehen hier weiter.
Wir werden das dann auch gleich
haustesten, noch
kurz zur Definition,
es gibt nämlich
zwei Art, es gibt Funktionen
und es gibt Methoden,
Methoden, zum Beispiel
haben wir das hier,
das hier,
das hier, zum Beispiel auch das Strip,
woran erkennt man eine Methode,
da haben wir nämlich
unsere Variable,
Punkt
und dann
unsere Methode,
und was Methoden so
anders zu Funktionen macht,
ist,
die geht her und schaut sich an,
was da drin ist
und praktisch
führt ihren
Funktionscode anhand
von dem Wert dieser Variable aus,
also wenn da jetzt eben
sagen wir mal,
so was,
dann kann man das eigentlich
so interpretieren,
das heißt,
wenn man das jetzt in eine Funktion
umschreiben würde,
wäre das dann so
und wir müssen das eben nicht machen,
wir können das eben so machen.
Und das ist eigentlich der Riesenunterschied
zu den normalen Funktionen,
wie ihr euch vielleicht
erinnern könnt, Funktionen
definieren wir
mit dem Dev Keyword
und Methoden sind meistens
schon definiert,
in diesen Kursen
machen wir eigentlich nichts mehr Klassen durch,
ja, will ich da auch nichts mehr dazu sagen,
aber eigentlich wichtig ist einfach,
das gehört dann zum Objekt.
Also da hat, ja, das ist dann ein bisschen komplizierter,
da könnt ihr euch dann das eigentlich
cyber recherchieren, falls ihr das genau rissen wollt,
aber eigentlich wichtig ist nur,
dass praktisch normale Funktionen mit dem Dev Keyword
definiert worden sind
und Methoden, also
nennen wir, wenn sie so was sind,
also mit diesem Punkt.
Dann kommen wir zu den
Return Values.
Ich müsste das jetzt so verstellen,
ich habe jetzt eine Funktion
und die berechnet mir jetzt was.
Sag mal, die macht 1 plus 2
und ich will diesen Wert aber
zurück haben,
dann muss ich das mit Return machen,
praktisch
ich
returniere diesen Wert
und dann gehen wir
praktisch,
kehren wir zurück zum Hauptprogramm,
das heißt dort, wo der Funktion
die Funktion aufgerufen wurde,
also sagen wir zum Beispiel,
wir haben ja x ist gleich 0,
dann haben wir,
rufen wir unsere Funktion auf
mit
x drin
okay, das sollte man vielleicht
y dazuschreiben.
Dann macht die intern irgendwas
Return diesen neuen Wert
und dann speichern wir uns dann in dieser Variable y.
Praktisch, die springt dann dort
zu hin, wo
diese Funktion definiert worden ist
und
dann springt sie eigentlich
wieder hier zurück
und dann
wird das
nächste hier ausgeführt.
Das heißt, wir können da bis
dem Kot herum springen
aber wir kommen dann eigentlich immer wieder
als das sobald das aufgerufen wird,
wird das abgearbeitet
und dann gehen wir eigentlich zum nächsten
genau das können wir zum Beispiel
sagen wir, wir haben hier dieses
Beispiel hier
diese Funktion format name
die bekommt 2
Parameter übergeben
first and last
dann kombiniert sie diese Parameter
hier mit einem Format string
in einen einzelnen string
dann rufen wir auf diesen string
also die umspeichern das hier in dieses
fullname Variable
und dann machen wir da noch fullname.title
und dann returner
diesen Wert, das heißt
was wenn wir hier in namet drinstehen haben
gehen wir mal das kurz durch
praktisch Arnold Schwarzenegger sind unsere Parameter
das heißt hier haben wir dann Arnold
und Schwarzenegger drinstehen
dann kombinieren wir das zu einem
einzelnen string
dann rufen wir
Deidlauf
das wandelt dann
diesen string hier mit
klein und großbruchstaben
in einen
schönen formatierten string
den returnen wir dann
und dann haben wir hier in name
jetzt Arnold Schwarzenegger drinstehen
da kann man natürlich auch
nicht nur strings oder einzelne integers
so was zurückgeben, da kann man auch
komplizierte Sachen zurückgeben
man kann listen, man kann
sets, man kann dictionaries
man kann alles mögliche zurückgeben
man kann auch mehrere mit beistrich
getrennt Variablen so zurückgeben
was man das haben möchte
das wird vom Beifen eigentlich
intern immer als duppel behandelt
das können wir auch kurz zeigen
hier habe ich einfach 3
das kann man sich vorstellen
sind wie 3 einzelne
Werte hier
und wenn wir da jetzt
cool aufrufen
sonst
seht ihr, bekommen wir das
als duppel zurück
wenn ich da zum Beispiel noch x definiere
kann ich das auch noch zurückgeben
und dann wird
praktisch dieser Wert von x
returniert
kann da auch noch
was komplizierter das machen
da habe ich da
x als dictionary
das kann ich auch noch
was komplizierter das machen
da habe ich da
x als dictionary definiert
das kann ich auch zurückgeben
wenn ich nur x haben will
geht das auch
da wird es aber nicht ein duppel umgewandelt
weil wir ja keine beistrische haben
und wir kommen wir praktisch nur
den Wert von x zurück
also return
gibt es praktisch
den Wert
der definierten Variablen hier
zurück
ist da zu fragen
dann kommen wir zu den Argumenten
also dieses Parameter
ich habe das jetzt mal hier
in rot und blau markiert
weil da gibt es 2 verschiedene
Arten wie ihr das machen könnt
da gibt es einmal
die Positional Arguments
die sind praktisch definiert
durch die Position
also hier
first
ist praktisch schon
an der 1. Position
das heißt wenn wir hier
einen Wert an der 1. Position
reinschreiben
dann wird das automatisch
in die 1. Position
also in dem Parameter
der an der 1. Position ist
reingeschrieben
wäre die z.B. an der 2. Position
dann würde es in
das zweite Argument reinschreiben
wir können das Ganze
aber auch mit Keywords machen
das heißt wir haben ja hier
diesen Funktionsparameter
praktisch definiert
der heißt der Last
den gibt es sonst nichts
also der ist hier wirklich
das 1. Mal definiert
das ist hier keine Variable
das ist hier praktisch
in dieser Funktion definiert worden
und wenn wir dann
eine Funktion aufrufen
dann können wir da praktisch
mit diesem Keyword
genau den Wert
für diesen Parameter
praktisch definieren
da gibt es dann noch
eine dritte Sache
und das wäre praktisch
dieser Default-Parameter
sagen wir zum Beispiel
wir haben eine Funktion
kann ich hier das Beispiel herzeigen
sagen wir hier haben wir eine Funktion
die uns den Namen
ausschreiben will
aber
wir überlassen
praktisch
wir haben nicht immer
das Land zur Verfügung
und dann können wir einfach sagen
wenn wir das Land nicht zur Verfügung haben
dann soll einfach
das Default praktisch als
normaler Wert
ausspär verwendet werden
das heißt wenn wir hier diese Funktion aufrufen
aber Country nicht angeben
dann geht
die Funktion davon aus
du willst einfach diesen Standard-Wert
hier drin haben
ich kann natürlich
warte
kann mich hier nicht mehr zurück
cool
ja dann machen wir einfach das her
geben wir ein paar Beispiele durch
sagen wir wir haben jetzt wieder
diese gleiche Funktion hier definiert
dann was kann ich machen
ich kann machen
nur positional Argument
das heißt praktisch
max wird hier in first
reingeschrieben
Muster wird in die zweite reingeschrieben
wir haben kein drittes positional Argument
deshalb wird da hier
Standard-Wert verwendet
wir können natürlich diesen Standard-Wert
überschreiben
dann machen wir einfach hier ein drittes positional Argument
dann steht hier nicht mehr in Country
als Standard-Wert
aus hier drin sondern wird überschrieben mit Germany
das gilt aber nur für diesen Funktionsaufruf
also der wird dann nicht
für immer überschrieben
für diesen Funktionsaufruf
dann können wir das gleiche natürlich auch mit keyword machen
also da können wir dann keyword
keyword angeben
das Interessante bei keyword ist, die sind jetzt nicht positional
also die können wir irgendwie umdauschen
sagen wir, wir wollen
zuerst das Country definieren
dann ist das vollkommen möglich
das Wichtigste ist nur
positional Arguments
sind immer vor den keyword Arguments zu verwenden
also wenn ihr hier
zuerst ein keyword Argument verwendet
und dann ein positional Argument
dann wird euch bei von einer Fehler werfen
das kann man jetzt auch kurz zeigen
eben
gibt es mehrere Fehler
die da auftreten können
zum einen eben
diese Argumentreihenfolge
die eben falsch sein kann
das heißt zum Beispiel, dass wir positional
keyword
positional Arguments nach keyword
keyword Arguments haben
können dann auch einfacher
Tippfehler sein
bei der keyword
Zuweisung, das heißt
wenn
last
hier zum Beispiel, wenn wir hier das a vergessen
dann wird peifen
uns auch einen Fehler werfen, weil
lsd
praktisch nicht definiert ist
sondern nur last
dann natürlich, wenn man zu viele Argumente
rein schreibt
positional Argument nach keyword Argument
nochmal, ja
es kann natürlich auch sein
dass wir dann in der Funktion
zum Beispiel
sagen wir, wir haben ja eine Funktion
die uns was addieren will
und wir gehen davon aus
dass wir hier integer bekommen
aber wir schreiben hier dann
max und muster rein
diese Funktion
dann
5 plus first
zu machen
das wird dann natürlich nicht funktionieren
da gibt es nämlich keinen check
dafür, dass da praktisch
das direkt ein integer ist
es gibt da schon typing, aber
wie gesagt, das ist dann
eigentlich schon wieder advanced
genau gehen wir da ein paar Beispiele durch
sagen wir, wir haben wieder
unsere Funktion hier
hier zum Beispiel
haben wir
ein Argument vergessen
hier haben wir praktisch nur
ein positional Argument
max, das heißt
first wird richtig überschrieben
aber mustermann fehlt
oder
muster
das heißt
er wird uns einen Fehler werfen
und sagt, da fehlt ein Parameter
den haben wir da nicht angegeben
so haben wir das zum Beispiel ausprobiert
sagen wir zum Beispiel
ich habe hier
erste
Parameter
jetzt haben wir hier
einen Parameter definiert
aber rufen hier cool ohne Parameter
dann kommen wir hier diesen type error
natürlich
wenn wir den hier als default
also mit einem
Standardwert definieren
ist das kein Problem
wie ihr seht verwend ich denn gar nicht
den Parameter, das ist nämlich auch vollkommen
egal, also
ich kann hier Parameter in der Funktion definieren
die ich aber nie wirklich verwende
da gibt es keinen Fehler
genau
dann gibt es natürlich auch so logische Fehler
zum Beispiel
wenn ich die positional Arguments
vertausche
zum Beispiel hier
habe ich
das Country davor
definiert
dass hier ist ein logischer Fehler
das passiert im Beifen hinter nix
weil der weiß ja nicht
dass du am Anfang den first name willst
und dann den last name
sondern
der weiß nur braucht drei Parameter
oder praktisch zwei
und einen default Parameter
der nicht unbedingt angegeben werden muss
dann
gibt es natürlich das auch
dass wenn das keyword falsch geschrieben ist
da wird auch ein Fehler geworfen
weil fs hier ist nirgends definiert
also hier haben wir kein fs
hier haben wir kein fs
was mit fs machen
aber das gibt es nicht
deshalb bekommen wir da auch ein Fehler
und
zu guter Letzt nochmal
praktisch positional Arguments
müssen immer vor den keyword Arguments sein
gibt es da zu fragen
ok
dann gehen wir das mal an einem tollen Beispiel durch
davor wir haben hier drei Funktionen definiert
und dann hier wird runProgram
aufgerufen
was passiert
zuerst wird mal hier
zu dieser Stelle
im code gesprungen
da haben wir dann
eine Variable definiert
die praktischen Liste ist
und die übergeben wir dann
einer zweiten Funktion
die wir hier definiert haben
das heißt
hier haben wir dieses Elements
das sind so neue Parameter
und hier übergeben wir
diese Variable
das heißt Elements
ist praktisch das gleiche wie
Standard Elements
also da haben wir praktisch die gleichen Werte drin stehen
und dann wird hier das Print aufgerufen
und dann geben wir hier
ein zweiter Print
da haben wir noch eine zweite Funktion
die aufgerufen wird
das heißt wir müssen zuerst
in diese Funktion reingehen
und da haben wir
dieses Elements wieder
das ist dann wieder das gleiche Elements wie hier
das ist aber ein anderes Elements wie das hier
sehr kompliziert
und dann
der macht uns ein FormatString
ListLength ist
und dann bekommen wir die Liste
von dieser Elements
Argument
da wichtig haben wir dieses Return
das heißt
wir gehen hier
wir schreiben dann
diesen ReturnValue
hier rein
und da bekommen wir dann praktisch
das Aus
praktisch das erste Print hier
List of Elements
das hier
und dann das zweite Print
schaut sehr kompliziert aus
kann am Anfang
vielleicht ein bisschen verwirrend sein
aber da kommen eigentlich die schnell rein
was ist zum Beispiel
da will ich euch ein Beispiel zeigen
da
was wenn wir sowas haben
ich definiere mir 2 Funktionen
diese Funktion ruft
die zweite auf
und die zweite ruft die erste auf
das heißt wir haben ja hier
eigentlich so eine Abschleife
und dann rufen wir sie auf
und dann wird das
hier aufgerufen, aufgerufen, aufgerufen
aufgerufen, aufgerufen
bis sie irgendwann sagt
bei sie sagen ah, irgendwas stimmt da nicht
also es ist nicht so wie eine Endlöschleife
sondern hier erreichen wir dann
ich habe es kurz davor erwähnt
praktisch es gibt auch Funktionen
die sich selber aufrufen können
das ist eigentlich sehr ähnlich dazu
irgendwann erreichen wir
dieses Rekursionslimit
das heißt
nach dem hunderttausendmal
sagt bei sie nahe zu Schluss
hier stimmt irgendwas nicht
also wenn ich das auch nochmal
kurz so zeige
ich muss mich zuerst definieren
dann kann ich da drin nämlich
die Funktion
nochmal aufrufen
die läuft und läuft und läuft
und dann irgendwann kommt zu diesen
Rekursionsfehler
für was ist so
eine rekursive Funktion eigentlich
notwendig
schauen wir mal da zum Beispiel so was machen
hier müssen wir noch
praktisch wie eine Schleife
die ruft sich immer wieder selber auf
also eigentlich ziemlich
dasselbe wie eine Weilschleife ist
nur dass wir die
Funktion selber aufrufen
was passiert
wir gehen hier rein
in diese Schleife
arbeiten hier durch
0 plus 1 ist 1
1 ist kleiner als 5
das ist wahr, deshalb rufen wir hier nochmal
A auf
das ganze geht nochmal rein
aber diesmal haben wir hier 1 drin stehen
1 plus 1 ist
dann geht es weiter
bis hier 5 drin stehen haben
dann ist dieses if nicht mehr erfüllt
und dann
passiert nichts mehr
dann gehen wir wieder hier zurück
da kommen wir auch noch zu einem
wichtigen anderen Thema
und das ist Scopes
und zwar wenn wir so Variablen definieren
die können ja
innerhalb und außerhalb der Funktion
definiert worden sein
und das nennt man Scope
praktisch haben eine andere Zugriff
Berechtigung
oder sind praktisch
nicht immer lesbar
hier zum Beispiel in grün
haben wir unsere globalen
Variablen definiert
warum sind die global
weil die außerhalb unserer definierten Funktion sind
und die können wir dann auch
innerhalb dieser Funktion verwenden
umgekehrt geht aber nicht
also wenn wir hier
hier im Blau zum Beispiel dieses Z definieren
das ist nicht
hier, das können wir nicht
außerhalb verwenden
praktisch nicht lesbar
außerhalb unserer Funktion
das können wir auch kurz testen
probieren wir mal das hier aus
also hier
haben wir unsere 2 globalen
Variablen 4 und 3
dann
printen wir hier Z aus
also die globale Variable Z
dann rufen wir
test.scope
auf
redefinieren wir Z
printen hier
einmal die globale Variable Y
und einmal
diese Funktionsvariable
Z
dann gehen wir wieder raus
aus der Funktion
und dann wollen wir nochmal
Z printen
was glaubt ihr
steht da im letzten Z drin
ist eine Tricksfrage
also es ist so
wir können
globale Variablen lesen
wir können sie aber nicht
überschreiben in praktisch
innerhalb der Funktion
das heißt wenn wir das jetzt ausführen
dann printen wir hier
unsere globale Variable Z
mit dem Bär 3
dann gehen wir in diese Funktion
dort printen wir die
globale Variable Y
weil wir können sie ja lesen
dann
versuchen wir aber hier Z
zu printen
aber wir haben die ja hier in der Funktion
einen neuen Wert zugewiesen
scheint zu mir so
dann gehen wir wieder raus
also das hier ist unsere Funktion
und dann wollen wir nochmal die
globale Variable Z printen
aber die wurde jetzt nicht
überschrieben
weil man in
praktisch innerhalb dieser Funktion
die globale Variable nicht überschreiben kann
das scheint ein bisschen kompliziert zu sein
am Anfang aber es ist
eigentlich eh selbstverständlich
wir können das ja auch nochmal hier ausprobieren
ah was hab ich hier ausprobieren
ich muss ja mal schauen was ich da programmiert hab
jetzt macht nochmal
dasselbe
wie
können wir da zum Beispiel
hergehen und Z
wirklich überschreiben
das geht natürlich
trotzdem
also da gibt es 2
Varianten wie man das machen kann
wir können einerseits sagen
ok wir machen
global Z
also wir wollen ja
wir wollen in dieser Funktion hier Z
die globale Variable
verwenden
dann machen wir einfach
das hier global Z
und dann weiß die Funktion
ok es gibt eine globale Variable Z
die wir in dieser Funktion überschreiben wollen
und da werden wir das jetzt ausführen
tatsächlich
ist hier dann nicht mehr 3 sondern 5
das global
solltet ihr aber nicht verwenden
ihr solltet
lieber sowas machen
und hier kommt dieses return
keyword
wieder ins Spiel
das heißt
wir definieren
hier unseren Variab
unseren Parameter Z
den wir überschreiben wollen
ähm
wir schreiben ihn hier
und dann returnen wir den
und dann machen wir hier einfach Z
ist gleich der Wert der hier rauskommen soll
und dann wird dieser Wert auch wirklich
überschrieben
ähm
genau
das heißt return Z
so wenn wir das hier kurz durchgehen
hier haben wir Z ist gleich 3
dann übergeben wir hier
den Wert 3
in dieser Funktion
also hier
die muss hier nicht Z
das heißt die kann hier auch was anderes heißen
Funktionsintern wird hier nur mit
den Werten gearbeitet
und nicht mit der Variable selber
das heißt hier wird
einfach nur der 3er übergeben
und nicht die Referenz
zu diesem Z
praktisch nicht die
Adresse falls ihr jetzt zurückrennen könnt
aber da kommen wir auch noch
kurz dazu
ähm
genau
und diese Sichtbarkeit
vom Variablen
also
Sichtbarkeit
wir haben ja hier jetzt
W definiert ja
ich kann W außerhalb
der Funktion nicht verwenden
dann bekomme ich so
Gelb
da steht W ist nicht definiert
warum ist das nicht definiert
weil es nicht im selben Kurzblock ist
das hier ist 1 eingerückt
deshalb ist
die Sichtbarkeit ist immer nur in einer Richtung
die geht nicht in beide Richtungen
genau
deshalb
habe ich da auch kurz davor
ähm
dass die Funktionsparameter Z
zu W umgenannt
weil selbe Name
lokal und global ist vermöglich
aber das führt dann zu Problemen
und das sollte man vermeiden
also am besten immer wenn ihr eine Funktion habt
den einen
den Parameter einen anderen Namen geben
wie außerhalb
genau
ja
hier zum Beispiel
was passiert hier
selbe kurz nachschauen
ähm
ok probieren wir das
kurz aus
ok sagen wir wir definieren
hier nicht Z
ähm
und definieren
erst danach
mal mache ich das da oben
das ist ein guter
wenn wir Z hier zum Beispiel
erst danach definieren
also nach dem Funktionsaufruf
aber hier
wir Z verwenden
wollen
dann funktioniert
sich das
im Moment trotzdem
weil wir da noch
ein Clubbitter verwenden
ja der
Clubbitter ist nämlich so
der ähm
kann sich im Hintergrund trotzdem diese Variable ab
ähm
deshalb könntet ihr auch später nochmal
verwenden obwohl sie erst später definiert wird
hier ist es dann so
dass praktisch Z erst nach dem Funktionsaufruf
definiert worden ist
also hier haben wir so
das hier ist ein Nähmauer weil hier
die Variable überhaupt nicht
definiert ist
genau jetzt haben wir es eben so
dass wir hier Z
verwenden wollen
aufs Volk gar nicht existiert
in diesem Fall haben wir
einen Nähmauer
denn Anbau und Local Error
muss ich nochmal nachschauen
warum der kommt
aber ja
genau also
wenn ihr hier in der Funktion
globale Variablen
verwendet
die aber erst nach dem Funktionsaufruf
definiert worden sind
oder in einer anderen Variable
Funktionen definiert worden sind
ähm
wie ihr seht hier
der Scope ist hier zwar identisch
aber das hier ist eine andere Funktion
und die Funktion kann nicht in diese Funktion
reinschauen
ähm
genauso kann
man hier nicht in diese Funktion reinschauen
also
ich kann nur von dem
nach außen schauen
genau das wäre eigentlich
schon das hier
ich weiß es ist jetzt ein bisschen komplizierter
soll ich da noch ein Beispiel machen
oder wollte
ähm
das ist eine Variable
das ist jetzt das erste
simples Beispiel also man kann sich da jetzt
natürlich denken
ok
zeige ich euch mal kurz ein anderes Beispiel her
schauen wir mal ob ich da eins hab
da oben glaube ich ist ja sehr gut
ja stell euch vor ihr habt so ein
Codeblock hier
ich hab hier ähm
praktisch die schauen ja sehr
sehr ähnlich aus oder
also wir haben hier praktisch hier nur
First and Last Name wo wir praktisch diese
Variable Namen verändern
aber zum Beispiel hier
dieses Full Name Punkt Title
und das Print Full Name das bleibt eigentlich immer identisch
für so was zum Beispiel ist es ultra nice
wenn man eine Funktion hat
oder was mache ich
ich warte, ich werde das euch da kurz mal
einfach so machen
und die Bekommt First
und Last
da haben wir unseren Code
drin
da müssen wir natürlich auch wieder
schauen, dass die Einrückung passt
dann
das ist der Code
und das kann man diese Full Name
Funktion immer wieder
verwenden aber mit anderen
Parametern das heißt
hier haben wir unsere 4, 5, 6
verschiedene Schauspiele
die wir hier alle nacheinander
ausgeben wollen
hier ist es so, dass wir das Ganze
dann einfach wirklich so machen können
Und das kann man dann zum Beispiel kombinieren mit Schleifen nicht, also das kann ich dann
auch noch kurz zeigen.
Ah, okay ja, muss ich zuerst das hier machen?
Okay, praktisch kann diese Funktion mehrmals aufrufen, da kann ich zum Beispiel sage ich
habe eine Berechnung, die ich immer wieder machen muss, dann habe ich mir diese Berechnung
hier in eine eigene Funktion rein und da kann ich die immer wieder aufrufen.
Zum Beispiel, das ist ja auch, ich zeige das da vielleicht am besten eher an der Assignment
1 Angabe, schau mal wo ich das habe, Angabe, immer Assignment 1, dann müsst ihr nämlich
nur Funktionen definieren, genau und zum Beispiel hier habt ihr so, dass ihr eine Funktion
erstellen müsst, die die Kreisfläche berechnet und natürlich sagen wir es ist jetzt wirklich
ein simples Beispiel, aber ihr könnt dann praktisch einfach hier diesen Parameter D
definieren in eurer Funktion und die Funktion dann mit verschiedenen Durchmessern aufrufen.
Das heißt, wenn ich erst die Fläche vom Durchmeister 1 haben will, dann bleibt innen
drin die Funktionslogik immer dieselbe, aber es wird natürlich ein anderer Wert ausgegeben
werden, als wenn ich da bei D2 drin stehen habe, zum Beispiel, ja, also für solche Sachen
ist normalerweise eine Funktion sehr hilfreich, wir machen hier natürlich nur ganz simple
Beispiele durch, das kann natürlich auch sehr, sehr kompliziert werden, ich weiß gar
nicht, ob ich vielleicht irgendein Beispiel habe, wie ich das vielleicht dann ausschauen
könnte, wenn man, ja, genau, also ihr könnt in eurer Damplate, dass ihr da runter lädt,
so viele Code-Zellen definieren, wie ihr wollt und da Code ausführen, zum Testen, was ihr wollt,
als das ist kein Problem. Genau, ja, genau. Schauen wir mal, ob ich da, genau so schaut es
zum Beispiel schon kompliziert aus. Wie ihr seht, habe ich hier eine Funktion definiert,
die mir zum Beispiel irgendein Programm, ein File öffnet und natürlich, wenn ich da mehrere
Files öffnen will, dann kann ich die einfach mal wieder verwenden. Und ja, wie gesagt,
also die Funktionen, die können dann sehr kompliziert werden, aber so kompliziert ist
in diesem Kurs hoffentlich nichts programmieren. Aussehewohl natürlich, dann könnt ihr es immer machen.
Genau, sonst gehe ich noch kurz assignment 1 die Angabe durch und dann, falls noch Fragen sind,
könnt ihr noch Fragen stellen. Genau, vielleicht kannst du anfangen. Abgabe-Termin ist hier,
vielleicht noch ein bisschen größer, ist der 9. November, da habt ihr bis Mittag nach Zeit.
Er erreicht praktisch die Abgabe wie bei assignment 0 im Decentre ein. Das Wichtigste ist
wieder wie bei Abgabe 0, dass ihr die sehr ab, also der Deinnahmen hier verwendet, also dieses
ipynb. Die Abgabe selbst soll assignment 1.ipynb heißen, die ja ein Code praktisch dann beinhaltet.
Ihr habt wieder diesen Commentator, da sollte ja wieder ein Namen ausfüllen,
hier auch wichtig den Pfeilnamen und ihr könnt auch diesmal eine Description hinzufügen.
Das ist eigentlich einerseits für uns wichtig, weil jeder gibt von euch assignment 1.ipynb ab.
Wie sollen wir sonst wissen, welches Pfeil gehört? Natürlich wissen wir schon trotzdem,
aber es ist trotzdem noch mal hilfreich, wenn man das Pfeil aufmacht, dann sehe ich sofort,
der Autor dieses Pfeils hat die Description und Comments. Das ist eigentlich nur für euch,
falls ihr das nochmal aufmacht, genau praktisch gleich in die Description reinlesen könnt,
okay, was habe ich da eigentlich gemacht. Ist es wirklich notwendig? Glaub nicht,
trotzdem für euch trotzdem einmal zum Ausdessen, auf jeden Fall.
Genau, automatisiertes Testen, also wir machen praktisch jeden Dienstag und Freitag bis
spätestens 18 Uhr könnt ihr eine Abgabeversuch tätigen auf dem Deepcenter und euer Notebook
hochladen und dann wird das durch unser automatisiertes Testsystem durchgelaufen und dann bekommt
ihr dann am nächsten Tag eine E-Mail mit einem Test Report.
Genau, so kannst du einfach so oft die überschreiben, wie du willst.
Genau, also bis zum 9. November wird nichts bewertet. Also da könnt ihr so oft abgeben,
ihr wollt es testen, getestet wird halt nur Dienstag und Freitag. Aber sagen wir zum Beispiel,
ja, macht es am Montag noch schnell Funktion, letzt die hoch und dann fällt ihr auf am Dienstag
vormittag, okay, nah, die Funktion habe ich, glaube ich, trotzdem noch nicht richtig geschrieben,
dann kann ich sie noch nochmal überschreiben und dann bis 18 Uhr dann wird sie getestet.
Aber da bekommt ihr noch keine fixen Punkte, also da wird auch nichts abgezogen.
Wichtig ist trotzdem mal so, dass das System testet jetzt nicht alle Sachen durch, das wird
erst ganz am Ende gemacht. Warum? Weil wir verhindern wollen, dass ihr das Testsystem
ausnützt, um da praktisch zum Inmax. Genau, wichtig Formatierung von Ausgabe und Rückgaben.
Genau, kleine Leerzeichen können eben schon, was war das hier? Genau, Ausgabe und Rückgabe,
kleine Unterschiede wie Leerzeichen, also wenn ihr zum Beispiel ein doppeltes Leerzeichen drin
habt, kann das schon zu einem gefehlten Test führen, also da genau schauen, dass die Ausgabe
stimmt. Wir verwenden dann auch noch das gleiche Testsystem, nur mit mehr Tests für die Benutung.
Ihr solltet deshalb auf jeden Fall zumindest einmal an einem Dienstag und Freitag pro
halber euren Code schon mal hochladen und durch das Testsystem laufen lassen. Zum Coding
Style, da gibt es ein eigenes Dokument. Praktisch, dass es dann zum Beispiel Coding Style in
ihr einhalten sollte, sollte zum Beispiel schauen, dass eine Zeile nicht länger als 120 Zeichen ist.
Zum Beispiel, das sieht man, hier sieht man es glaube ich nicht. Genau, also hier müsst ihr
aufpassen, dass ihr nicht mehr als 120 Zeilen in einer Zeile habt. Man kann sich das glaube ich
irgendwie auch anzeigen lassen. Einrückungen, da bitte schauen, dass ihr genau vier Leerzeichen
verwendet zur Einrückung und normalerweise könnt ihr da eh die Setup, das die verwenden,
die sollte euch dann eh automatisch vier Leerzeichen einrücken. Manchmal macht es mit zwei oder mit
acht. Das kann man in den Einstellungen normalerweise einstellen. Variablen Namen und Kommentare müsst
ihr auf Englisch machen. Es ist zwar eigentlich eine deutsche Vorlesung, aber die Code sind alle
Englisch. Deshalb solltet ihr das in meinem internationalen Standard befolgen. Zu den
Variablen Namen praktisch klein Buchstaben für Variablen, Argumenten und Funktionen
und falls die aus mehreren Wörter bestehen, trennt ihr die nicht mit Leerzeichen, weil Leerzeichen
funktioniert nicht mit diesem Anderscore. Genau, der Klassen und Exceptions machen wir
eh nicht durch. Konstantin ist auch egal. Genau, ihr solltet auch immer schauen, dass der Variablen
Namen dazu passt. Also hier zum Beispiel Letters stimmt hier nicht. Ihr solltet das vielleicht eher
Digits nennen. Das wird aber jetzt glaube ich nicht vom Testsystem jetzt direkt bewertet. Also,
das wird höchstens manuell durchgeschaut. Genau, ihr solltet auch nicht so ein nicht
aussagekräftiger Variablenamen verhindern oder nicht verwenden, zum Beispiel eben so. Die ich
eigentlich immer jetzt an der Vorlesung verwende, das ist eigentlich ein No-Go, aber es ist halt
sehr schnell und zum Testen halt sehr praktisch. Schaut auch, dass ihr dann nicht sowas verwendet,
wie ListDictBool. Also, wenn ich da vielleicht noch mal zurückgehe,
ihr solltet das verhindern. Das sieht man eigentlich eh den Unterschied. Das hier ist so in den Lila
Violette und hier überschreibe ich das Ganze. Also, das ist im Beifen durchaus möglich. Sollt
ihr es machen, besser nicht. Sonst wird nämlich dieses Digi-Word hier einfach überschrieben mit
dem String A hingegen, wenn ich das hier so mache. Das habe ich dann natürlich,
das wird eigentlich hier so verwendet. Und jetzt haben wir auch schon das Problem. Jetzt muss ich da
den Kernel restarten. Genau. Warum habe ich da zum Beispiel den Kernel restarten müssen? Das liegt
daran, dass Jupiter intern sich das hier genau merkt, was ich hier reingeschrieben habe. Das heißt,
hier habe ich x mit dem Wert 5 definiert und jetzt kann ich da in eine andere Code-Seile davorgehen
und x aufrufen. Wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel den Kernel restarte, dann werden alle Werte gelöscht
und jetzt sagt er mir, x ist nicht definiert, weil x erst hier definiert wird. Das heißt, wenn ich es
dann hier mache, dann hat jetzt x einen Wert und jetzt kann ich x wieder hier aufrufen und jetzt
geht es. Also, das könnte euch auch öfters passieren, dass ihr eben so einen Fehler bekommt. Das liegt
wahrscheinlich daran, dass ihr x in Wirklichkeit erst weiter unten definiert habt, aber x schon
weit oben verwendet. Ihr schließt der neue Visual Studio Code, öffnet es dann wieder und plötzlich
habt ihr praktisch eine neue Jupiter-Instanz, das ist praktisch wie restart kernel und plötzlich
steht da im x nichts mehr drin und bei dem weiß nicht, was los ist. Also, das ist auch so ein
gängiger Fehler, der vielleicht auftreten könnte. Ja, zu den übermäßigen unerwünschten Ausgaben,
das ist so, die sind eigentlich nur der Fall in eurer wirklich definierten Funktion, die ihr
ausprogrammieren müsst. Zum Testen könnt ihr so viele Prints reinhauen wie ihr noch wollt. Das
ist euch dann vollkommen, euch selbst überlassen, wenn ich mir richtig erinnere.
Genau, Imports ist jetzt eh nicht so wichtig. Ihr werdet es in der ... Sie selber nachschauen.
Das ist kurz das hier beenden. Das hier ist der neue assignment 1 Notebook.
Hier ist dieses Importmarf drin. Was das Import macht, es fügt euch noch Büberticken hinzu und hier
in diesem Fall die Bübertikmarf. Das heißt, wenn ihr später unten irgendwas mit Marf aufrufen müsst,
aber hier diese Zelle nie ausgeführt habt, ich kann das jetzt kurz mal ausruhen. Hier in diesem
Fall will ich B. Dann geht das nicht, weil ich nie diese Zelle ausgeführt habe. Das heißt,
bei euch im assignment schaut das ja immer diese importmarf Zelle mal ausführt, damit ihr auch Marf
verwenden könnt. Ja, dann schauen, dass der Teilnahme richtig ist.
Also, das Baskivert solltet ihr eigentlich auch nicht dann in eurem Code verwenden. Ihr solltet auch
immer schauen, dass ihr da wirklich was macht in der F-Statement, weil wenn ihr euch das ja anschaut,
das könnte man einfach zu dem hier umformen und ihr solltet auch immer schauen, dass ihr
praktisch dann nicht solche empty Statements habt. Da einfach das umdrehen und dann habt ihr eigentlich
dasselbe nur halt statt den vierzeilen in zwei Zeilen. Genau, globaler Variabel sollte man auch
vermeiden. Ich glaube, die habt ihr ja eh nicht notwendig. Dann gibt es auch noch so Spezialfälle,
zum Beispiel, wenn ihr hier eine Liste habt, die ihr definiert habt, dann solltet ihr da nicht mit
einer Indizierung durchgehen, sondern ihr könnt dann eben direkt diese Laufvariable so beschreiben,
genau überschreiben. Also, vorhin, wenn möglich, schaut das ja nicht range-lang names verwendet,
sondern direkt in names. Weilschleifen sollten für solche Sachen überhaupt vermieden werden.
Also, Weilschleifen, normalerweise verwendet ihr nur für Input-Sachen, also in eurem Use Case,
sonst wenn so eine Liste vorkommt, verwendet das hier. Also, die normalen vor in names.
Ja, Verschachtelungen so wie möglich übersichtlich behalten. Dickt Update solltet ihr auch nicht
verwenden. Es gibt zwar, aber macht lieber sowas. Das Update ist nur verwirrend und es ist eigentlich
nicht mehr so gebräulich. Genau. Das ist zum Coding-Standard, erlaubte Module und Beifen-Packages,
wie gesagt, die erlaubten Module sind in der Template schon vorhanden. Ihr sollt generell keine
zusätzlichen Module praktisch importieren, die habt ihr normalerweise auch nicht notwendig.
Ja, zu Chatchapity und Co-Pilot und so weiter und so fort. Da aufpassen, ich würde euch raten,
das nicht zu verwenden. Vor allem, das hier sind noch sehr simple Aufgaben, die ihr sicher, man
braucht am Anfang vielleicht bis in der Weltzeit das Ganze zu verstehen. Aber wenn ihr das selber
macht, am Anfang, dann ist es später viel, viel einfacher, wie das wieder zu verwenden.
hingegen, wenn das jemand anders für euch durchprogrammiert, werdet ihr es nie erlernen und
das ist leider ein bisschen schade. Deshalb versucht sowas wie Chatchapity und Co-Pilot, wie
möge ich es nicht zu verwenden, vor allem beim Vorprogrammieren und so habt ihr es dann auch nicht
wirklich, könnt ihr es nämlich auch nicht verwenden. Also das seid ihr dann wirklich
allein, auf euch allein gestellt. Dann besten wirklich kurz mal alles selber durchprogrammieren und
dann sollte es eigentlich kein Problem sein. Gibt es da was zum Testen noch?
Ja, genau zu den Aufgaben selber. Da müsst ihr ein paar simple Funktionen selber definieren,
also genau das, was wir heute gemacht haben. Genau, zum Beispiel hier diese Funktion hier
muss was ausprinten. Was hier ganz sinnvoll ist für euch ist, ihr könnt hier einfach diesen Text
kopieren und dann müsst ihr nun praktisch das ja umändern und der restlichen Text habt ihr
da schon stehen dann und der ist dann praktisch identisch zu dem, was wir auch im Testsystem
dann checken. Statt wenn ihr das wirklich hergeht und selber ausschreibt, dann kann es eben nämlich
vorkommen, dass ihr zum Beispiel solche Fehler macht, wo dann das Testsystem vielleicht sagt,
ah das ist nicht ganz korrekt, hier sind zwei Leerzeichen, hier ist ein Großbuchstabe drin.
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, was man hier zum Beispiel verwenden könnte bei diesen King Klammern,
damit man hier diese full name Variable verwendet oder verwenden kann? Zum Beispiel darf das da jetzt
nicht das richtige Beispiel hernehmen, aber sagen wir zum Beispiel hi und hier will ich meine
Namen drin haben. Wie kriege ich diese Variable hier in diesen String rein? Genau, mit dem Format String.
Das heißt, hier macht man dann einen F daraus, das können wir so behalten und da diese größere
Kleinerzeichen wollen wir weg haben. Wichtig hier, diese größeren Kleinerzeichen sollten dann im
Endergebnis nicht mehr drin sein und da kann ich zum Beispiel das machen. Das heißt, der Wert von
Name wird dann hier in diesen Format String reinhaut. Wenn ich das F nicht habe, geht das nicht.
Genau, dann die Kreisfläche berechnen. Dann hier habt ihr noch eine größere Funktion,
die ihr schreiben müsst. Hier müsst ihr nämlich selber eine Funktion schreiben, die die InfoBW-Note
berechnet. Das ist so, der habt ja ganz unten dann immer definiert, welche Parameter dieses
Funktionen bekommt. Das heißt, wir haben hier sechs Parameter, die haben dann auch den bestimmten
Datentyp, das könnt ihr eigentlich ignorieren. Hier ist es nur für euch gut zu wissen, was es ist.
Also hier habt ihr anscheinend ein True-False-Value, hier habt ihr einen Gleitkommazal, eigentlich hier
habt ihr überall dann einen Gleitkommazal. Und dann hier ganz unten habt ihr noch,
was die Funktion zurückgeben soll und das macht ihr mit Return und Return bekommt die berechnete
Note, wenn eine Note vergeben wurde und sonst dieses Nann, wenn der Studierende keine Note erhalten hat.
Genau, da müsst ihr dann eben hier mit der bisher Logik implementieren, mit if-elef-else. Dann habt
ihr noch was über Vorloops. Also da müsst ihr dann über Listen drüber iterieren. Als iterieren
heißt einfach, ich hau es in den Vorloop rein und dann wird praktisch das erste Element und
das zweite Element und das dritte Element praktisch iteriert. Genau, dann müsst ihr dann
Sachen zusammenfügen und da ist auch wieder Parameter und Return-Values sind dann ganz
immer zum Schluss. Ja, diese Parameter ist das hier. Ich definiere mir meine Funktion,
ja mit def, dann habe ich hier Funktionsname ja und das sind meine Parameter. Param1,
Param2, Param3 und die heißen zwar Parameter, aber innerhalb der Funktion sind das praktisch
einfach dann Variablen. Also ich kann dann einfach Param1 hier ganz normal verwenden.
Visual Studio Code zeigt die dann halt in anderen Fahrwerden, die zeigt die dann halt so in rot und
k, zum Beispiel so in leicht orange an, falls der Parameter nicht verwendet wurde und Return
ist praktisch das hier. Ja. Genau, was das Testprogramm macht ist,
du hast hier deine Funktion definiert, das Testprogramm extrahiert diese Funktion,
ruft dies bei sich aus und dann schaut, ob der Wert hier mit, also schreibt dann hier andere
Werte rein, also die, die ihr nicht bekommen habt, sondern die wir für uns definiert haben.
Die Programmlogik wird dann von euch ausgeführt, also wird von der Funktion ausgeführt,
ob die ihr definiert habt und dann schauen wir, ob dieser Wert hier stimmt oder falls
der Print verwendet, ob die Print-Ausgabe gleich ist. Genau, und dann könnt ihr da eben,
also in diesem Fall ist Param1 ja hier mit, mit dem Wert 1 dann vergeben und dann addieren wir
hier noch bei diesem Param1, eins dazu und dann gehen wir das zurück und dann bekommen wir eben
hier zweit, also hier haben wir dann den neuen Return Wert, dann können wir dann in einer neuen
Variable zum Beispiel speichern. Genau, das sind dann zwei Aufgaben mit Vorloops,
die ein bisschen komplizierter sind und dann habt ihr noch was mit Z-Stictionaries,
wo ihr praktisch ein paar Set-Operationen durchführen müsst. Also hier, wie ihr seht,
nochmals eine Wiederholung, Set, die haben hier keinen Doppelpunkt, die haben ja nur einen Beistrich,
also so praktisch wie eine Liste, dann wisst ihr, ah ok, mit der geschwunden Klammer ohne Doppelpunkt,
das ist ein Set und ihr sollt ihr hier in verschiedenen Set-Operationen durchmachen.
Und hier der Return Value ist praktisch einerseits ein Doppel, das ist das mit den
Rundenklammern und das Doppel, also wenn ich das hier kurz wirklich hinschreib,
werdet ihr sowas rauskriegen, wir haben hier ein Doppel, also Klammer auf, ein Set,
da steht anscheinend irgendwelche Strings drin, dann haben wir ein Beistrich,
dann haben wir noch ein Set mit Strings drin, dann haben wir noch ein Set und noch ein Set
und dann ist unser Doppel zu Ende. Also der Datentyp hier beim Return Value zeigt euch
ungefähr, was für eine Struktur ihr zu erwarten habt. Wenn ihr euch zurückerinnern könnt, wenn ich
sowas mache, sagen wir mal, ich habe hier paar Variablen definiert, das hier zum Beispiel,
sagen wir mal, diese Variablen sind alle Strings, dann wäre das sowas.
Doppel String String String.
Also es steht normalerweise dabei, ob ihr es aus, also brinden sollt oder nicht. Also ganz wichtig,
ich schaue ganz kurz, schauen wir mal, ob wir ein gutes Beispiel finden, hier. Also wenn da
dieses normalerweise ausgeben steht, dann heißt das, ihr sollt was brinden. Wenn das jetzt nicht
steht, dann müsst ihr nichts brinden. Meistens ist eh genau schon der String definiert, den ihr
dann ausgeben sollt. Wie gesagt, ihr müsst dann vielleicht manchmal mit Format Strings oder Strings
mit anderen Strings addieren, damit ihr zu diesen erwünschten Ergebnissen kommt. Und dann wenn Return
steht, dann müsst ihr was returnen. Es gibt zum Beispiel ganz am Anfang die erste Funktion hier
zum Beispiel, die hat gar kein, kein Parameter und keine Rückgabewerte. Da steht nochmal was dabei,
falls es kein Rückgabewerte hat. Ja, genau. Und dann müsst ihr bei den letzten zwei einmal mit Z
was machen und einmal mit Dictionary bis sie iterieren und da was machen. Und ja, gibt es dazu
noch Fragen? Okay, dann war es das eigentlich von mir. Danke.